[Music]
here's a rule that will never steer you
wrong the second worst thing the
government does are the things that
democrats do by themselves the third
worst are the things republicans do by
themselves but the worst of all are the
things that the two sides agree to do
together the bipartisan things
so
one example which we
may tragically see again in the near
future are all of the disastrous
military conflicts we've been involved
in over recent decades those were all
bipartisan
um
things
here's another example perhaps slightly
less serious but but maybe not
and it happened yesterday when the
senate passed by unanimous consent the
so-called sunshine protection act
i haven't heard of a bill
this uh misleadingly named since the you
know don't don't say gay bill even
though that wasn't really the name of
the bill the sunshine protection act
this bill greeted with much applause and
fanfare by many in the public would make
daylight savings time permanent
now that's not to say that it would
abolish daylight savings no it would it
would keep us stuck in daylight savings
eternally
the hour that we lost when we jumped
ahead a few days ago will never be
recovered it's gone forever it's
banished to purgatory never to be seen
again
now the idea behind this proposal is for
one thing to uh end the silly ritual
where we switch our clocks back and
forth arbitrarily that's the part that
most everybody can agree with and i
agree with you know we've been switching
our clocks back and forth for decades
nobody knew why nobody wanted to do it
yet the daylight savings tradition
continued lingering on hanging there
uselessly like some kind of vestigial
limb and it was time to end it
that's good but the question is whether
we end the tradition by making daylight
savings permanent or by reverting back
to standard time and just leaving the
clocks there
out of these two options congress of
course has chosen the worst one electing
to turn daylight savings into a chronic
condition
two of the senators behind this ploy
marco rubio and edward markey
wrote an op-ed for cnn congratulating
themselves and extolling the brilliance
of their plan they wrote
we can always we can't always get
bipartisan agreement in congress these
days but here's one thing we can agree
on
we could all use a bit more sunshine
that's why we're working together in the
u.s senate to make sure we end the
practice of spring forward and fall back
by making daylight savings time
permanent
yes they say the sunshine protection act
will literally protect the sunshine by
giving us more of it now i find it
necessary to point out that no matter
what the clocks say
there will be exactly the same amount of
sunshine regardless
now congress may imagine itself to be
powerful enough to literally control the
sun itself but it's not
we're not giving ourselves more sunshine
this way we're not giving ourselves
anything we're merely agreeing by
legislative decree
to permanently pretend that it's an hour
later than it really is but why
why are we doing this
where did this come from what the hell
is going on
well let's go through a brief history of
this madness and i i think most of what
i'm about to say is basically true but i
didn't care enough to look it up so
we'll just we'll go with it
daylight savings was first proposed by i
believe benjamin franklin as a joke
250 years ago
he told it to his buddies at a bar and
everybody laughed and said ah there's
old benny again with his wild schemes
and for the next 100 years people
continue to laugh at the joke and then
in the 1890s a weirdo bug collector
named george something or other decided
that he wanted more time after work to
stare at crickets and beetles this this
megalomaniac actually wanted to shift
time itself
just to accommodate his pointless hobby
one hobby that i enjoy is night fishing
okay i like to go out fishing at night
but you don't see me suggesting that we
blow up the sun so i can do it more
often
that's essentially what george wanted to
do slightly less drastic but still a
significant change
now fast forward to 1918 when daylight
savings time was officially instated
here in the usa
our lawmakers at the time they didn't
say they were doing this so that a guy
named george could look at beetles
instead they said that we were doing it
for a few reasons most importantly to
save energy
now
how could changing the numbers on a
clock save energy
how could it achieve anything at all who
knows but we did it
and since then studies have proven that
this policy like almost all government
policies you can name utterly failed to
achieve whatever it was supposed to
achieve it didn't save energy it didn't
force the sun to give us more daylight
it didn't usher in an era of utopia it
didn't do anything
except annoy everybody
and now after a hundred years of this
failed government policy
the government's decided to do what it
always does when a policy fails which is
make it permanent
if it didn't work do it more
that's the motto of our elected leaders
but many people in the public are are
celebrating this policy as i mentioned
they insist that this will now give us
more sunlight during waking hours
of course what they apparently don't
realize is that there's another way to
have more sunlight during waking hours
wake up earlier
but no people don't want to wake up
earlier they don't want to adjust their
schedules instead they prefer to
manipulate time itself or try to
manipulate i mean
you could either adjust your schedule or
adjust time itself
which one should we do oh i know well
just time
this is how lazy we've become as a
society
never mind the fact that your extra hour
of daylight after work now means that
school children are going to be walking
to the bus stop in the pitch black for
several months out of the year
maybe some safety hazards there you
think that'd be enough reason not to do
this
but who cares about safety if it means
that you can have more sunlight after
work sunlight that you're going to
squander anyway by just sitting on your
couch and watching netflix i like all
these people pretending i want more
sunlight when i get home from work so i
go for a jog you're not jogging you're
going to sit on your couch on your phone
is what you're going to do stop
pretending otherwise
what we should be doing it's obvious
is abolish daylight savings entirely and
revert back to standard time
now standard time is a human construct
in the sense that any method of
measuring time will inevitably be a
human construct but it was far less
arbitrary okay standard time
was more closely aligned with the body's
circadian rhythm and with the rising and
setting of the sun
that's why standard time was devised
that's where it comes from
in fact it's it's more important for
your body and your mind to have sunlight
in the morning than at night
it's not natural to have sunlight that
late at night
your body wants to wake up with the sun
that's how we're designed
daylight savings is unnatural it's an
attack on nature and creation itself
we will have to answer for this come
judgment day
one other point not to make too much of
this
too late i guess
but there's another serious problem as i
was discussing this on twitter yesterday
many people insisted that um well we can
and should make daylight savings
permanent because time is an illusion
it's a construct and we can do with it
whatever we please
this of course is completely false our
method of measuring and keeping time is
a construct but time itself is real time
is simply the progression of reality
from one moment to the next time ensures
that everything won't happen all at once
time is what keeps you from getting
eaten by a t-rex time is the movement
and flow of existence
yet these claims from the anti-time
agitators only show how congress by
making daylight savings permanent has
undermined faith and confidence in the
reality of time itself
the united states senate has caused many
people to question the very meaning and
existence of time
they've created a mass existential
crisis
one which threatens the foundations of
human society recklessly the senate
passed this bill without even grabbing
grappling with these questions and
implications without even first
establishing
what time is where it comes from or if
it exists at all
are the past and future but illusions
are we trapped forever
in eternal now
legislation raises these questions
doesn't answer them
and now we're lost
mass anarchy madness
and despair will be the result
so not much of a change on second
thought i guess even so for all these
reasons
i hereby declare that as far as i'm
concerned
daylight savings is cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated